ist jetzt sagen wir mal das die
Konsequenz aus dem was wir jetzt
besprochen haben
und und tatsächlich ist long koved etwas
was was mich ein bisschen besorgt macht
und zwar deswegen weil ich
diese Menschen auch als Kardiologe sehe
und in der Funktion bin ich ja heute
prima mal hier
die kommen nämlich weil sie Symptome
haben und Beschwerden die ganz ähnlich
sind wie Menschen mit einer
Herzmuskelschwäche so die Patienten die
nach einer akuten Kurve 19 Infektion
genesen sind insofern dass der PCR-Test
negativ ist dass die akute Infektion
abgeklungen ist häufig geht es den kurz
ein bisschen besser und dann geht sie
ihn wieder schlechter oder es geht ihnen
gar nicht mehr so richtig besser und es
geht ihnen immer schlechter über Wochen
und Monate und daher kommt der Begriff
auch lonkovit die werden nicht mehr
richtig gesund über einen längeren
Zeitraum und die Symptome die die
Menschen berichten und es waren vorher
das sind häufig junge Menschen die ich
sehe sind in unserem Umfeld auch
Mitarbeitende der Charité Ärztinnen
Ärzte Pflegekräfte andere das sind
25-Jährige 30-Jährige sportliche
Menschen die können nicht mehr die haben
eine erhebliche körperliche
Leistungsschwäche sie haben eine rasche
Ermüdbarkeit sie haben Kurzatmigkeit bei
geringer Belastung sie können Dinge des
täglichen Lebens nicht mehr verrichten
sie haben Konzentrationsschwäche
Konzentrationsstörungen Schlafstörungen
Herzrhythmusstörungen
und die geraden tatsächlich in einem
verzweifelte Lage und das ist etwas was
nicht ganz selten ist ich habe mir dazu
jetzt mal die Zahlen noch mal
rausgesucht also wenn man jetzt auch
größere internationale Untersuchungen
anschaut dann kriegen etwa zehn Prozent
der CO wird erkrankten dieses long kovic
Syndrom mit den Symptomen die ich gerade
geschildert habe keine
Leistungsfähigkeit Schlappheit rasche
Ermüdbarkeit Kurzatmigkeit 10 eine Frage
ja den Haarausfall habe ich auch gelesen
ist auch noch ein Symptom von Long Kurve
sogar als der häufigsten laut den
Studien aber eine Sache die Deutsche
Gesellschaft für
Pneumologie und beatmungsmedizin sagt
dass die Häufigkeit von lancobit sehr
schwer zu erfassen ist woher können Sie
dann also definitiv sagen dass es durch
Corona kommt weil zum Beispiel die
Gesellschaft sagt es ist sehr schwer zu
erfassen ob es jetzt wirklich diese 10%
bei dir der Zusammenhang schwer zu
erfassen ist korrekt der Zusammenhang
ist schwer zu erfassen und natürlich
sind diese ganzen Symptome auch ein
wenig unspezifisch so und dann kommt
nämlich der Teil 2 warum kommt denn
diese Menschen zum Kardiologen ich sag
mal wir haben zum Beispiel an der
Charité ein COBIT 19 und lonko wird
Netzwerk da sind absolut die Experten da
da gibt es zum Beispiel unser Chronik
fatigue Center das ist ja dann in der
weiteren Entwicklung des chronische
fatig-syndrom mit der Frau Professor die
das
scheibenbogen die das leitet wo sicher
dass es die zehn Prozent sind also die
das leitet die diese Menschen sehen
diese zehn Prozent sind Literaturangaben
ich persönlich bin da nicht sicher ob
das acht oder 14 Prozent sind aber es
ist ein relevanter Anteil an Menschen
und jetzt sage ich Ihnen mal meine
Erfahrung also ich sehe zum Beispiel
Menschen die sind Sportler gewesen und
jetzt sind sie zwei drei Monate nach
ihrer kovid-infektion arbeitsunfähig und
es gibt auch viele Impfung waren
2020 anders gewesen wie jetzt ich ich
bin nicht sicher ob es anders gewesen
ist vielleicht
gucken wir jetzt genauer hin erkennen
das eher ich als Kardiologe kann nur
sagen ich kenne diese
Situationen aus der Vergangenheit bei
jungen Menschen die eine virale
Myokarditis hatten
da gab es ganz gelegentlich genau solche
Situationen und diese Menschen sind von
Pontius zu Pilatus gerannt also ich
kenne ich kenne das auch im privaten
Kreis ich habe also
eine große Erleichterung nein
sagte weil sie machen eigentlich
deutlich dass es ein Feld in dem
geforscht werden muss das muss
untersucht werden die Aussagen die sie
ja bewusst schwach formulieren liegen ja
nicht daran weil sie das nicht sagen
können sondern weil die Datenlage fehlt
die Datenlage fehlt aber deswegen weil
mich erhoben wird es wird nicht
untersucht also nach meinem passen also
ich habe mich damit lass uns einmal noch
ein Experten reinholen denn genauso wie
Herr Piske ist ja auch Herr Frank Arzt
wie schätzen Sie das denn ein mit long
covert eine Frage noch unterscheiden sie
bei den jetzigen Patienten mit nach
Virusinfektionen kovid und einer
kardiomyokarditis in ungeimpfter
Patienten erfassen Sie das statistisch
also
die Zahlen die die wir jetzt sehen noch
die geben das noch nicht her um das zu
erfassen das habe ich befürchtet also
Herr Professor Piske ich bezweifle mit
keinem Moment dass sie in hervorragende
Kardiologe sind und ihre Patienten bei
Ihnen auf Station hervorragend behandelt
werden ich möchte sie dennoch massiv
kritisieren für das was sie gerade
gesagt haben erstens das Myokarditis
Problem ist ein Problem der Impfung bei
jungen Männern da steht sogar in der
neuesten publikationsjacke vom
Zirkulation das kennen Sie
wahrscheinlich da steht das explizit
drin es ist die Impfung die die junge
Männer
bedroht eine Karte Myokarditis zweitens
wir haben keine auffällige Sterblichkeit
in den corona-jahren 2020 bis Mitte 21
Fakten tut mir leid sind zahlen müssen
sein wir haben eine auffällige
Sterblichkeit der 30 bis 55-Jährigen ab
Mitte 21 als die Impfkampagne angefangen
hat ich sage nicht dass das die Impfung
ist also das sieht wirklich seriöse
Schätzungen der 6000 Menschen zusätzlich
gestorben sind die sonst nicht gestorben
werden
dann es wird nicht dann haben sie diese
Studien wo sie sehen an
muskelbiopien am Herzmuskel dass die
Impfung dort eine autoimmung Geschehen
auslöst so und jetzt haben wir die
Gefährdung durch die Impfung was ihr
Gebiet angeht und wir haben eine
kurveterkrankung die lassen sich jetzt
wieder Ausreden nein Herr Schröder das
geht nicht sie können jetzt nicht
einfach sagen sie können jetzt bitte sie
können jetzt bitte nicht einfach mich so
unterbrechen ich darf das jetzt sagen es
ist wirklich jetzt fachlich sehr sehr
fachlich sehr wichtig ja also sie haben
die Gefährdung durch die Impfung und sie
haben die Gefährdung in seltenen Fällen
durch covid 19 das zusammen addiert
bringt jetzt durchaus das Problem was
Sie sehen aber ich möchte endlich eine
Publikation sehen die das Problem was
sie schildern bitte trennt in geimpfte
mit kardiomyopat viral und ungeimpfte
und jetzt longkowitz es gibt genügend
Untersuchungen die zeigen dass diese
typischen Symptome die heute alle da
rein vermengt werden ja
konzentrationstörungen Müdigkeit und
dergleichen genauso bei Patienten
aufgetreten sind die nicht covid hatten
ich finde wir reden hier über long
Lockdown und long Maske es gibt die
echten lonkovit-patienten die meistens
mit dem Chronik
fertiges-bar-virus und diese Patienten
haben leider von der Medizin nicht viel
zu erwarten das ist leider so wir haben
noch nicht wirklich Therapien für diese
Patienten aber wir tun diesen Patienten
kein Gefallen wenn wir aus lohnkovit ein
Riesenthema machen was es nicht ist es
ist für die meisten Beschwerden die
damit eingerechnet werden ist es long
Lockdown long Maske und die
Kardiomyopathien da hätte ich gern mal
eine saubere Untersuchung die
unterscheidet geimpft und nicht
geimpflichte wir erleben da dass das
Herr Frank ist ja nicht einmal
unterbrechen darf
long Kowitz oder aufgrund der Impfung
ich natürlich das Thema
Impfnebenwirkungen sehr ernst nehme
kommen natürlich
selektiv besonders viele Patienten mit
impfenwirkungen das ist so die Patienten
mit ich habe zwei drei Fälle oder ein
Fall wo man sagen kann was durch die
Impfung auch aufgetreten ist also ich
erzähle ihnen einen Fall von letzter
Woche ja und ich habe täglich solche
Fälle das ist auch besonders
eindrücklicher ein junger Mann 17 Jahre
ja aus Mülheim wie heißt das Land ich
habe aufgeschrieben Myanmar ja also
früher Burma da gibt es Programme die
quasi Eltern überreden ihre Kinder nach
Deutschland zu schicken für ein
schulstipendium und diese Mutter hat
eingewilligt der junge Mann kam nach
Heidelberg hat den schulstipendium
bekommen und hat dort drei Kurve die
Impfungen bekommen weil er einfach ein
teilhaben wollte am Leben mit seinen
Mitschülern seit vier Monaten kann der
seine Beine nicht mehr belasten und das
ist typisch ich habe bestimmt 30
Patienten gesehen die genau dieses
Symptome nach der Impfung hatten es ist
ein Neurom wiederes Problem das ist
bekannt es gibt jetzt wirklich 100 von
Publikationen die das beschreiben und
dieser junge Mann kann kein Sport mehr
machen kann ich mir tanzen kann nichts
und jetzt kommt's weder die Schule
erkennt das an dass das mit der Impfung
zusammenhängt noch die Kollegen die
lassen den alleine im Regen stehen und
wissen Sie was seine Mutter in Myanmar
in den Bürgerkriegsgebiet bereut es
bitterlich dass sie ihren Sohn ins
reiche Deutschland geschickt hat wo er
geschädigt wurde und wo das einfach
ignoriert wird und das finde ich ein
Armutszeugnis für Deutschland wir können
nicht mehr so mit den Impfschäden
durchgehen ich meine jetzt sind wir mit
meinem Thema schon gelandet ja aber Sie
können direkt weitermachen
also Stopp jetzt entschuldigen sie mal
sie haben angefangen an haben eine
wissenschaftliche Arbeit aus England
zitiert und die haben sich komplett
falsch zitiert komplett falsch zitiert
sie haben genau das Gegenteil gesagt von
dem was da drin steht ein harter Vorwurf
ja da steht nämlich drin dass es
nach Impfungen auch zu einer
kardialen Mitbeteiligung oder
Myokarditis autoimmun vermittelt kommen
kann das aber die Häufigkeit
nach der Impfung viel seltener ist als
die Häufigkeit wenn ich an kovit
erkranke und die Kurve Impfung schützt
mich genau vor dieser Komplikation aber
es kann auch durch den Raum auftreten
nein ich habe sie haben es wirklich
falsch gelesen es steht eindeutig drin
ja dass man nicht unterschieden hat man
hat zwar Unterschieden bei geimpft und
ungeimpft aber man hat nicht bei der
Auswertung Unterschieden umgeimpft
umgeimpft man hat nur die geimpften und
die myokratiden verglichen mit den
myokardiden nach kovit aber man hat
nicht unterschieden ob die da geimpft
oder umgeimpft waren und der Schlusssatz
in der conclusion Zirkulation wir reden
über diesen Artikel und der Schluss hat
bitte lesen Sie ihn nach da steht kein
Artikel da steht glasklar drin das
größte Risiko für die für die jungen
Männer ist die zweite Impfung und nicht
covid 19 steht wortwörtlich drin also
bitte werfen Sie mir nicht vor dass ich
die Stute ich kann also ich finde das
ich kann mit so etwas also erstens sie
behaupten die ganze Zeit Kausalitäten
Corona eigene Studien sie beschreiben
Fälle die sie in beobachten und stellen
eine Kausalität her wo sie sagen die
Impfung ist schuld daran dass das
passiert das behaupten sie sie haben
nicht einen einzigen Beleg bisher dafür
benannt und das finde ich schwierig wenn
also mit sowas könnte ich jetzt nicht
bzw auch Fälle an der Charité
geschrieben mit long Kove
was ich persönlich auch für dringend
notwendig halte ist das sind wichtige
Aussagen die müssen untersucht wir haben
sie werden aber nicht untersuchte
Problem
gesagt hat also kurz
bei geimpften ist es so dass man oft
schon Symptome hat bevor man überhaupt
ansteckend ist weil die Impfung führt
dazu dass sozusagen der Körper sehr
schnell reagiert noch wenig wie Russland
und dann erst kommen die Viren und dann
steigt die Virus das sind wir uns auch
einer der Gründe weshalb quasi die
Impfungen die Pandemie begrenzen weil
sehr häufig sind die Leute schon mit
Symptomen unterwegs und bleiben dann
auch zu Hause noch bevor sie wirklich
ansteckend sind weil bei demjenigen der
geimpft ist die Symptome oft beginnen
bevor die Viruslast sehr hoch ist